>>> YOU GUYS KNOW THERE'S
NOTHING UNUSUAL ABOUT A GROUP OF
RETIREES MOVING INTO AN
EXCLUSIVE GATED COMMUNITY IN
FLORIDA EXCEPT WHEN THE RETIREES
ARE TEN -- LOOK -- 10,000-POUND
ELEPHANTS.
I THINK THEY'RE VERY CUTE.
AND FAMOUS ONES AT THAT.
THESE ELEPHANTS USED TO PERFORM
FOR THE RINGLING BROS. BARNUM &
BAILEY CIRCUS.
AND ONLY ON "CBS THIS MORNING"
-- I'M GOING TO SAY IT AGAIN --
ONLY ON "CBS THIS MORNING,"
MANUEL BOJORQUEZ GIVES US A LOOK
AT THEIR NEW HOME.
AN EXPANSIVE NEW HABITAT IN
RURAL FLORIDA.
♪
>> Reporter: JUST SOUTH OF THE
FLORIDA/GEORGIA LINE, A HERD OF
GENTLE GIANTS NOW ROAMS.
THEY ARE AS BIG AS THEY ARE
MAJESTIC.
MEMBERS OF THE LARGEST ASIAN
ELEPHANT HERD IN THE WESTERN
HEMISPHERE AND RETIREES FROM THE
RINGLING BROS. BARNUM & BAILEY
CIRCUS.
EARLIER THIS SPRING, THEY WERE
SHIPPED HERE -- THEIR LUSH NEW
HABITAT AT THE WHITE OAK
CONSERVATION CENTER.
FOR CONSERVATIONIST MICHELLE GAD
IT'S A DREAM COME TRUE.
>> A LOT OF KIDS HAVE A DREAM OF
RUNNING AWAY TO JOIN THE CIRCUS.
I WAS THE KID WHO WANTED TO LET
ALL OF THE ANIMALS OUT OF THE
CIRCUS.
♪
>> Reporter: ELEPHANT
ATTRACTIONS WERE A PART OF
RINGLING BROS. BARNUM & BAILEY
CIRCUS FOR MOST OF ITS 146-YEAR
HISTORY.
IN 2016, RINGLING FINALLY
RETIRED THE ACT AFTER YEARS OF
PUBLIC OUTCRY ABOUT WHAT MANY
CONSIDERED ANIMAL CRUELTY.
THEIR RETIREMENT WASN'T PERFECT.
THEY WERE MOVED TO THIS SMALL
PRESERVE SOUTH OF ORLANDO.
SO LAST FALL THE NONPROFIT
WALTER CONSERVATION STEPPED IN
AND BOUGHT THE 35 ELEPHANTS AND
BOUGHT THE HABITAT.
THEY WERE FINALLY ABLE TO ROAM
AND FEED AND BOND AS A HERD AND
EVEN COOL OFF WHEN THE FLORIDA
SUN BECOMES A BIT TOO MUCH.
ELEPHANTS ARE AMONG THE MOST
SOCIAL AND EMPATHETIC ANIMALS
THERE ARE.
AND HERE NOT ONLY ARE THEY
GETTING TO KNOW THEIR NEW
SURROUNDINGS, THEY'RE GETTING TO
BETTER KNOW EACH OTHER.
>> THE TWO OLDEST GIRLS, I REFER
TO THEM AS THE MEAN GIRLS, BUT
PERHAPS THEY'RE JUST A LITTLE
BIT BOSSY.
>> Reporter: THIS IS THEIR FIRST
TIME REALLY INTERACTING AS A
HERD.
>> IT'S THE FIRST TIME
INTERACTING AS A HERD.
THEY SEEM TO HAVE SORTED OUT A
HIERARCHY AMONGST THEMSELVES.
THEY REGROUPED RIGHT OUTSIDE THE
FENCE.
AND AGAIN, REASSURED EACH OTHER,
RUMBLED, TOUCHED EACH OTHER, PUT
THEIR TRUNKS IN ONE ANOTHER'S
MOUTHS.
>> Reporter: NICK NUBEE LEADS
THE PROJECT AND WORKS WITH THE
ANIMALS EVERY DAY.
HE KNOWS THEM ALL BY NAME, EVEN
IF THEY'RE ONLY SHOWING THEIR
B
BACKSIDES.
>> ANGELICA, SARAH, MABEL,
MYRTLE --
>> Reporter: HE SAYS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE BEEN RAISED AND
TRAINED AND BECOME DEPENDENT ON
HUMANS, SENDING THEM INTO THE
WILD IS NOT AN OPTION.
BUT HERE, HE HOPES THEY CAN HELP
HUMANS BETTER UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THIS ENDANGERED
SPECIES OF WHICH ONLY ABOUT
50,000 REMAIN.
SO WHAT IS YOUR MISSION FOR THEM
HERE?
>> JUST FOR THEM TO LIVE A
HOLISTIC LIFE AND A REALLY
COMPLETE LIFE.
THE BEST THING FOR THESE ANIMALS
IS TO LIVE IN A COMPLEX
ENVIRONMENT THAT'S PRETTY DARN
CLOSE TO THE WILD, HONESTLY.
>> Reporter: THIS IS AS WILD AND
FREE AS THEY CAN BE.
>> I BELIEVE SO.
YES.
>> WE WANT PEOPLE TO REALIZE
THAT ELEPHANTS ARE BEAUTIFUL
JUST AS THEY ARE.
THEY DON'T NEED TO BE RIDDEN OR
TRAINED OR DO TRICKS OR TRAVEL
THE WORLD.
JUST LET THEM BE WHERE THEY ARE,
AND YOU DON'T GET ANYTHING MORE
BEAUTIFUL THAN THAT.
>> Reporter: BACK OUT HERE AT
THE WATERING HOLE THIS MORNING,
AND THE ELEPHANTS ARE CLEARLY
STILL SLEEPING IN.
WHILE THERE ARE POSSIBLE PLANS
FOR VIEWING AREAS AROUND THE
HABITAT, WHITE OAK HAS NOT
DECIDED WHETHER THEY WILL BE
PART OF PUBLIC TOURS.
AS FOR THE OTHER ELEPHANTS
VIRTHAT
HAVE NOT YET BEEN TRANSFERRED,
THERE'S NO SOLID TIMELINE ON
WHEN THAT WILL HAPPEN BECAUSE
NEW HABITAT IS STILL BEING
CREATED, AND THE SUMMER MONTHS
ARE TOO HOT FOR A MOVE.
TONY?
>> ALL RIGHT.
THEY'RE RETIRED.
THEY CAN SLEEP IN.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, I LOVE
THAT THEY GOAT /T GET TO SLEEP .
>> I LOVE NICK KNOWS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE ELEPHANT
BUTTS.
THEY ALL LOOK THE SAME.
IT'S SO NICE THEY GOATET TO PON
AND CUDDLE.
>> BEAUTIFUL ANIMALS.
WATCH WHERE YOU STE